اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفاتي هذا المساء
اعترافات خطيره
ينشرها عبر الانترنت
ضد امريكا
متطوره من شركه اسرائيليه لقوه الدعم
السريع السودانيه ماذا تعني وهل هي مجرد
عمليه تجاريه فقط ان المساله اكبر من ذلك
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى تفاصيل في سلسله تغريدات على
حسابه العربيه على مصر تويتر قدم المنشد
الايراني علي خمن اعترافات يقر فيها
بتدخلات بلاده في شؤون الدول
قال ان القضاء على العمق الاستراتيجي
لايران خطه رسمها الامريكيون بمليارات
الدولارات والالف الساعات من العمل الفكري
من اجل الحق الضرير بايران لكن هذه الخطه
احبطتها ايران بحسب قولك مضيفا في تغريدات
اخرى انا الامريكان قرروا شل دول الجوار
وهي العمق الاسراتيجيه لايران قبل قرار
لشن العدواني على ايران وقالوا اي
الامريكيين انه يجب علينا ان نطيح دول
الست وهي العراق وسوريا ولبنان وليبيا
والسودان والصومال قبل مهاجمه ايران ليؤكد
خامنئي في تغريده اخرى تدخل بلاده في دول
المنطقه بالقول ان ايران لم تدخل الى شمال
افريقيا اطلاقا ولكن في الدول الثلاث اي
العراق وسوريا ولبنان نجحت سياسته ايران
واخفقت امريكا
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف بيروت مصطفى فحص الكاتب
الصحفي ومن بغداد الدكتور عدنان السراج
رئيس المركز العراقي لتنميه الاعلاميه ومن
اسطنبول البحث في العلاقات الدوليه
الدكتور عمر عبد الستار اهلا بكم ضيوف
الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا بصيد فحص سيد
فحص نحن امام في الواقعه تصريحات واضحه لا
تقبل التاويل يقول فيها خمينا ايه بان بعض
الدول هي تمثل العمق الاستراتيجي لايران
كانت هذه التعبيرات تستعمل كمقربات او
تستعمل
في قراءه معينه ولكن ان يقول لها خامنئي
في هذا التوقيت ما الذي يعني
مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك المشاهدين نعم مع
السيد خامنئي او المرشد الايراني
تتحدث هذه المره عن ما يمكن تسميته
بالمجال الحيوي الايراني
لاسباب عديده قد يكون السبب داخليا بانه
بانه هناك سؤال ايراني داخل يجب النظر
اليه حول ما تقوم محاوله ما تستثمره ايران
في الخارج وبدا يقوم وبدا يتحول الى
حساسيه لدى المجتمع الايراني او لاغلبيه
الايرانيين فهو يقول للايرانيين عامه وحتى
وللمحتاجين ان ما تقوم به ايران في الخارج
على حساب الداخل هو لحمايه هذا النظام
باعتقاده ان الايرانيين كما المجتمع
الايراني والتركيبته كما نخب النظام لديهم
هواجس توسع هواجس توسعيه في ايران حاله
معينه او في النظام الايراني هناك حاله
غريبه الاطوار هي دائما الايران تبحث عن
فائض في خرائطها فائض في الخرائط او في
المجال الحيوي هو البلدان مثل لبنان
والعراق وسوريا واليمن ولكن الوصل
الجغرافي التركيز هو لبنان هو بغداد دمشق
همم بيروت ايران عندما نظرت الى هذه
الخرائط لم تنظر الى ساكنيها لم تعرض
اهتماما للمكونات المجتمعيه في هذه
البلدان فكك وولت عليها ايضا قوه سياسيه
تعمل لمصلحه ايران وليس للمصلحه للمصلحه
الوطنيه لذلك حكمتها او تحكمت بها بقوه
بنوعين من القوه اما بقوه بفائد
الاستراتيجي الايراني
من خلال قوه قمعيه مسلحه عقائديه اي بي او
او ما يمكن تسميته الاسلام السياسي الشيعي
المسلح الولائي الذي هو
لديه ازمه في في التركيبه في تعريف الهويه
الوطنيه كما يحدث في العراق لديه ازمه
في لبنان لذلك اصبح هناك ما يمكن ان يوصف
بالمساله الشيعيه في لبنان
هذه النقطه هل لديكم دكتور عدنان ازمه
هويه فدخل العراقي حتى ان البعض لما كان
يطرح مثل هكذا قراءات استاذ عدنان هل
تسمعني
ممتاز ضيف يقول بان في العراق
مراقبون يعتبرون بان هناك ازمه هويه وهذه
القراءه في الواقع كانت همم يعني تطرح في
ما قبل هو يطرحها مراقبه وهو محللون ولكن
العراقيين كانوا يعترضون على ذلك ويقولون
بانه هناك تعاملونك على قدوليه ولكن لم
اساس بساده العراق اليوم هناك تاكيد من
ايه فهل تفتقد العراق للهويه الحقيقيه
ذاتيه
شعب شكرا على استضافه تحيه لك واللي ضيوفك
العزاوي يشاهدك الكرام خلي بنتكلم بشكل
عام بان المدى يعني الذي تستخدم في
العناوين في المجال الحيوي او المدى
الحيوي كما يسمى في العلوم السياسيه هذه
امور ثابته في الواقع السياسي بين كل
الدول يعني ليس ايران هي وحدها تختص بهذا
الجانب كل الدول في العالم يعني تضيق هذه
القضيه المجال الحيوي حسب قوه الدوله
الاجتماعيه والعسكريه والثقافيه وايضا حسب
الموقع الجغرافي وحسب بالامكانيات الاخرى
هذه الامور ثابته في الواقع السياسي في
العلوم السياسيه امريكا تستخدمها الغرب
يستخدمها روسيا تستخدمها الان دول صغيره
وغريبه متى ما وجدت المساحه همم يعني
متاحه فهي تتوسع بهذا المجال بحكم الواقع
السياسي الذي يفرض بقاء الدوله وحيويتها
دي العراق بالتاكيد طرحت الهويه الوطنيه
ولكن طرح مقابلها تعدد الهويات فلذلك طاقه
الحاجه الى ان يكون ان تكون الهويه العنصر
الاخر في التجربه النمساويه في العراق
عندما قيل بان الهويه الوطنيه يمكن ان
تتقسم على القوميات وعلى الاثنيات ولكن
يجب ان يفكر برفاهيه المواطن اي بمعنى
رفاهيه المواطن تسبق هويه المواطن كيف هل
يمكن ان يكون هويه المواطن بعناوين
الرفاهيه دون ان تكون هناك قوه داخليه
متماسكه تستطيع ان توفر هذه الامكانيات من
كل النواحي وتستطيع ان تقف امام التصورات
لدول الجوار والدول الاخرى العالميه لان
مجال الحيوي نستخدم العراق جزء من سياسات
كما يحصل اليوم في صراعات الدول الاقليميه
والعالميه على العراق وهذا واضح جدا
العراق هل سيدفع طبيبه هذه التصورات بسبب
ضعفه بالتاكيد هذا شيء لا يمكن احد ان
ينكره
السلام عليكم كل ما يكون النظامه وهشه كل
ما تكون القوه الخارجيه تحاول محافظ
بان هذا الشيء عادي بالعوده الى المتغيرات
بالعوده الى الحسابات الجو السياسيه التي
يشهدها العالم بالعوده الى همم اسميته
بالمجاله الحيوي هل هناك همم يعني هل يمكن
القول بان هذا عادي
هذا هو الفروع عفوا حضرتك تقول بانه
المجال الحيوي يطرح مثل هكذا او يفرض على
الدول مثل هكذا تدخلات او استفاده من همم
همم سياسات بعض الدول ولكنك في نفس الوقت
تعتبر بان الحكم العراقي الحالي ضعيف
فسؤالك هل عادي ان تستبيح ايران الداخل
العراقي همم لانه ضعيف
بشكل عام ان يتكلم بشكل عام بتضمنها ايران
اي دوله تجد الواقع للدول الجوار الذي هي
تحتاج الى المجال الحيوي كل دول العالم
تحتاج الحيوي باسباب عديده كما يعني
استلفت في مقدمه الموضوع اليوم مثلا
الموقع الجغرافي للعراق يجعل الامريكي
تفكر بالعراق ان يكون مجال الحيوي وتحاول
ان تبسط نفوذ كذلك ايران لكن كل ما يكون
علاقه قويه انا اقول اليوم الحكومه
العراقيه طبعا بمسلسل الاحداث السابقه
اتضح ان العراقيين ليس بدها السهوله ان
يبتلعونا بشكل واضح من دول الجوار او من
دول العالم من خلال همم النظريات التي
يطبقت في العراق من خلال سوره العراقي في
ان يحافظ على وطنه هذا امر اصبح واضح حتى
ادري ايرانيين وكل حتى
تكون
سعيد عبد الستار ما رايك همم هل ترى كذيفه
الدكتور عدنان الموضوع
يدخل في اطار همم
استفاده بعض الدول من السياسات او من
سياسات دول الجوار ودول المنطقه همم او
ترى خط احمر لا يجب تجاوزه بان ايران اقرت
همم
بتدخلها في هذه الدول وبانها تمثل لها
عمقا استراتيجيه كما قالت
تحياتي للضيوف الكرام وللمشاهدين يعني
احنا شفنا اللي صار منذ 79 الى اليوم اربع
حروف خليجيه بصراحه
واذا فقط نقدر نشابه صدام بايران نعم هذه
المشابهه صحيحه لكن لما السعوديه تتوسع
ولم تركيا يتوسع ولم نجد ان مصر تتوسع لان
هذا هو ناصر اقليمي الحقيقه اما اذا يتكلم
على الولايات المتحده لانه هو اصلا هذا
النظام الفوضوي النظام الدولي او طبيعي
تقبل بوجود دوله مثل ايران وتقبل بوجود
الدوله مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه او
مصر او تركيا لانه العراق اذا تكلم عن
العراق باحتلال 2003 وهو محيط جيو سياسي
لتركيا وايران المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لماذا لم يتدخلوا كما تدخلت همم ايران
المشكله في تدخل ايران مثل ما ذكر الدكتور
مصطفى المشكله في تداخليه ايران انا تتدخل
باعتبار ان الدوله يعني بين قوسين كائن حي
وهذا الكائن الالتهامي عليه ان يتمدد علي
ان يصدر ثورته عليه ان همم لا يكون للدول
المجاوره اهميه هو يسمى نفسه الخلفائد
الحزام يعني القلب والراس والقلب والراس
الكل في خدمته في العراق ليس دوله كما هي
ايران سوريا ليست دوله كما هي ايران لبنان
ليس دوله كما هيا ايران ولذلك اتفاقيه
سايكس بيكو او الحدود الوطنيه المعروفه
التي جاءت بعد 1920 لم تكون موجوده
الاشكال عندنا في العراق او في سوريا او
في لبنان ان الذين يعارضون منهج ايران
بالقاعده وجيش المهدي او بالحشد وداعش لا
يستطيعون ان يعملوا شيئا وطنيا ولا
يستطيعون ان يعيش المشتركا لان كل هذه
الاشاره الموجوده سواء كان بشار او نصر
الله او الحشد او الحوثي يعملون لخدمه
القلب والراس ما الخامه نيئه داخل ايران
وهذا هو نظريه المجال الحيوي انه اني
كدوله مركزيه في هذا التراكم ان يجب ان
نعيش لكن هذا السعوديه
في تركيا ولا تلقاه في مصر ولا تلقاه في
الاردن لا هذا هذا هي الفكره مال مال هي
فكره بالاساس المانيه وها الفكره اللي اخذ
بيها هتلر وهتلر ادى به الى ان يذهب الى
حربين عالميتين بمئات يعني بملايين القتلى
وتدمير ربما يعني جزء كبير من هذا العالم
وتغير في النظام الدولي اني ارد اقول لها
في هذا الموضوع انه عندما يقوم خامنئي او
اركان نظام خمني بكشف استراتيجيه هذا
النظام او هذا المجال حيوي يعني معناته
انه لماذا يكشف هذه الاستراتيجيه يحتاج
الى اكثر من رده الداخلي يحتاجه اذا اكو
اندفاع اكو حماسه مثل ما صار بالعواصم
الاربعه من قال على اليونيسف مستشار
روحاني في حين كما اعتقد قال العراق عاصمه
الامبراطوريه الايرانيه هذه الفكره فكره
ان هذه الدوله بها مجال حيوي والمجال
الحيوي هو التمدد خارجها على حساب الدول
هذا فكره جهنميه انا قادم من الجحيم نحن
بالعراق قادمون من الجحيم لا يوجد في
العراقي
فكره جهنميه يعتبرها ضيف يا دكتور عدنان
فكره عاديه هذا المعمول بها ليس كذلك
دكتور عدنان
في كل دول العالم قضيه المجال الحيوي لا
يعني الاحتلال يعني عندما يتعامل هتلر او
ممثلين او ستالين حول الانضمام دول له لا
يعني ان هناك تقارب فكريا او تقاربا يعني
اجتماعيا او مصلحه مصالح انما مصالح
احتلال لتقويه دولته اليوم لا السعوديه
ولا ايران ولا كل هذه الدول تستطيع ان
تحتاج الدول بهذه العناوين ان ما هي قد
تحتاج مجالها من اجل تقارب في الدين تقارب
في اللغه تخالف في المصالح الاجتماعيه
وبالتالي تحقق الاستقرار في النظام
السياسي هذه النظريه يعني بعلوم سياسيه
متعامل بها وانت بس احنا في كل الجامعات
وكل دول العالم بتعمله ولكن عندما تتحول
الى عمليه التدخلات في الواقع السياسي وفي
النظام السياسي وفي تشكيلاته هذا طبعا
بالتاكيد هذا يعتبر تدخل غير مقبول حتى
عدول الاخرى التي ترى بان العراق
مثلا مثلا
ترى بانه العلاقه بين ايران وبين العراق
هي علاقه تبادل تجاري همم
ثقافي الى اخره وليست تدخل في شؤون العراق
بايجاز هذا مواد الطرحه صحيح
في جانب معين في جانب معين نعم تعرفين
العلاقات العراقيه الايرانيه لست صحيح
طبعا
الاقليميه الكبرى من الطبيعي ان يكون لها
دور لا احد يستطيع ان يمنع تركيا ان يكون
لها دور او مصر او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وحتى ايران في الجغرافيا تحكم
ولكن هناك فرق كبير ما بين الدور والنفوذ
النفوذ في الطبيعه الايرانيه انما تكون
النظام مسكونا بهواجه امبراطوريه والسوريه
وثاره يستخدم العقائد من اجل المشروعه
الخاص وليس لمشروع الاخرين فهو يبني في
العراق او في سوريا او في لبنان ما تحت ما
يحتاجه نظامه السياسي وليس ما تحتاجه تلك
الدول لذلك النفوذ بالطبيعه الايرانيه هو
نفود يؤدي الى فك فكه المجتمعات والى
تدمير الدوله يستطيع دكتور سراج ان يصف
لنا حاله الدوله في العراق وما بنته ايران
في فائض خرائطها ايران اعتمدت على اللا
دوله او ما دون الدوله او الى جانب الدوله
ونمت مؤسسات على حساب الدوله لانها تريد
لان المشروع الايراني بطبيعتها العقائدي
او الجيو عقائديه لا ينمو مع اي دوله
مستقره ت- تطرح فكر هويتها الوطنيه وفي
العراق جرى عده همم تحولات الحرب على داعش
الاعاده الاعتبار او المصالحه السنيه مع
بغداد
الاستفتاء والانتباه الكردي الى الخصوصيه
العراقيه ثوره تشرين المجيد 2019 التي
اعدت اعاد شيعه العراق تعريف هويتهم
الوطنيه وهمم وجاءت نتائج الانتخابات
لتثبت اعاده هذا التعريف وهذا ما لا يمكن
ان يناسب مشروع النفو الايراني
فالحرائق التي نبتت في المشروع الايراني
نستطيع القول في العراق انها حرائق نبتت
شيعيه اي ان المجتمع الشريعي العراقي الذي
اعاد تعريف هويته في الانتفاضه وفي
الانتخابات هو من حمل مواجهه النفوذ
الايراني وليس كرها بايران ولكن اعاده
الاعتبار لوطنيته يفرض عليه ان يقف في وجه
المد الجوعائد لايران واذا كانت ايران
دوله طبيعيه لها دور والجميع يحترم الدور
الايراني في المنطقه عليها ان تتعامل مع
العراق وليس كنفود لان النفوذ الايراني في
العراق وفي سوريا وفي لبنان تحول الى
هيمنه وكان هذه البلدان غنيمه تستخدمها
امبراطوريه او قياده تعيش بها الجسم
هذا الخطاب وهذه التصريحات الخامنائي هل
هذه الدول في حرج ام حضرتك تعتبر بان هذه
الدول المتواطئه او خلينا حتى نكون دقيقين
ولا نستعمل بعض المصطلحات التي تكون في
محل ليس متواطئ ولكن ما باليد حيله همم
حضرتك ترى بانه هناك حرج لهذه الدول او
بالعكس هذه الدول تتعامل مع تعاطي ايران
مع دخلها ومع سيادتها ومع سيادتها كما
يتوافق مع سياسه الايرانيه تستخدمهم كعمق
استراتيجي كما يقول ايه
والحقيقه خليني اذكر ثلاثه اسباب الرئيسيه
ادت الى هذه الايش
اللي انا سميتها انه المحيط جهنم اللي
اللي هو في العراق وفي سوريا وفي لبنان
اول شيء بصراحه مجتمعاتنا في العراق وفي
سوريا وفي لبنان بصراحه فاقد المناعه
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه لو لم تكون فاقد
المناعه الاجتماعيه والسياسيه لن تستطيعش
ايران
بظل نظريه المجال الحيوي ان تفعل بهم ما
فعلت وبالتالي على هذه المجتمعات ان ان ان
يكون لها مناعه اجتماعيه وسياسيه تمنع
نموذج مثل ايران ان يدخل شمالا او ان ياتي
جنوبا في هذا الموضوع فبالتالي اول مش اول
سبب لهذه العقليه او المنظومه بين قوسين
ما يسمى بالمجال الحيوي الايراني التي
تلتهم الدول بهذه الطريقه وتقول لا فرق
بين العراق وايران هو علينا نحن العراقيين
والسوريين واللبنانيين قبل ايران هذا واحد
يعني يجب ان تكون لان هو معركه دوليه يجب
ان تكون حديث اللي في الدولي هاي واحد
اثنين بالنسبه لايران كمان كمان كانت ترى
بالنسبه لهتلر لان هي اصل الفكره من
المجال الحيوي هي فكره المانيه واستخدمها
هتلر وذهب لكي يكون
لالمانيا دور كبير امام بريطانيا وامام
روسيا فمن هنا هتلر تواجهوه تواجهوه
وتحالفات دوليه ثانيا ربما تكون امكانياته
غير قادره على على تلبيه طموحي نفس الشيء
بالنسبه
له حضرتك بالقول بان ايران التهمت هذه
الدول همم باي معنى
لا لا سياده في هذه الدول لا وطن هناك في
هذه الدول لا دستور في هذه الدول من يتحكم
في هذه الدول في الجيوش تابعه لقاني لهذا
قواني يتحدث وسلام يتحدث وقام نهائي يتحدث
وحيدر مصلح يتحدث انه نحن موجودين في
العواصم الاربعه فعلا ونصيتر على العواصم
من اربعه فعلا يقولون هكذا في لحظات من
الحماس والاندفاع والتوتر اما النقطه
الثالثه والمهمه فانه لمواجهه هتلر كمال
لمواجهه ايران بهذه النظريه لابد من تحالف
من دولي ولا بد من العقوبات عقوبات الضغط
الاقصى متى ياتي التحالف الدولي لمواجهه
ايران كما ذهب لمواجهه هتلر هذا هو السؤال
لكن انا اعتقد نحن سبب اولا ايران سبب في
نظريتها والنظام الدولي الذي يسمح لهذه
الدول الفضيه بان تلتهم سياده الدول هو
ايضا مسؤول من اجل المحافظه على هذا
النظام الدولي من هنا انا اعتقد المساله
الثلاثيه فيها ابعادها وتحتاج بالتاكيد
الى حلول ثلاثيه ولذلك نحن بدون ان نكون
حليب لتعلم في العلاقه وفي سوريا او في
لبنان لا احد ربما سيطرق بابنا من اجل ان
ننتقل من الله استقرار الى الاستقرار ما
رايك همم سيد سراج في هذا الكلام هل ترى
بان العراق مثلا من بين الدول التي
اتهمتها ايران او ان هناك مبالغه في القول
ذلك
غير صحيح اليوم ليس هتلر والذي بدا
بالمجاري حيوي انما هو بسمارك وكافور
الذين وضعوا اسس الدوله الالمانيه
الايطاليه هذا وضع ذلك على طول اليوم
المجال الحلوي ليس برنامج المجالس حيوي هو
مصطلح سياسي همم تدرس في العلوم السياسيه
بعنوان حاجات البلد البقاء على الاستقرار
السياسي هذا واضح في كل دول العالم حتى
العراق يفكر في مجال الحيوي في اماكن اخرى
اين عمق الاستراتيجي هل العربي هل الاسلام
هل الدولي ثم ان الهويه الوطنيه في العالم
اختي العزيزه اليوم تساقطت قضيه الهويه
الوطنيه الشيعه يملكون الهويه الحقيقيه
لبناء دوله ام وقفوا مع بناء الدوله منذ
تاسيسها هذا حتى قاتلوا مع الدوله
العثمانيه ضد الانجليز في الشعيبه وفي
القرنه وقدم التضحيات من علمائهم وغير
علماء فذلك الهويه في مساله استعداد
العراق للحفاظ على سيادته هذه موجوده ولكن
عندما نطرح الهويه الوطنيه بهذا العنوان
في العصر الحديث يقال بان الوطنيه هي
عنوانها ان تكون رفاهيه المواطن هي الهويه
هي الاساس من خلال التعاون مع الدول
العالم
العقبه في التعويمه الاسلاميه
همم باحترام وبرام بكرامه
انا مستعد ان اوافق على هذه التعريف
الهويه كما قال الدكتور سراج اذا كان هناك
دوله في العراق او في لبنان او في سوريا
تحترم المواطن لا دوله في النظام بشار
الاسد يفتخر في براميله التي يرميها على
الناس فاين تحترم المواطنين اما في العراق
فالدكتور يعرف اكثر مني حجم ضعف الدوله
والتدميرها وتفكير والتفكير الاجتماعي
بسبب والرفاهيه التي يعيش فيها العراقي
نحن نتالم على الفتره الملكيه في العراق
وترحم على الباشا سعيد ليته يعود شيء شبه
مثله يعيد نوع من الرفاهيه حتى رغم انك
كانت هناك مظلوميه همم المظلوميه الاطراف
في العراق بزمن الملكيه ولكن الهويه على
في مجتمعاتنا العربيه هويه مركبه لها
خصوصيات ولكن الدوله عندما تكون قويه تبني
هويه وطنيه تعرف بها خصوصيات الامه وهذا
غير موجود لا في العراق ولا في سوريا ولا
في لبنان وايران لن تسمح لان ايران وضع في
هذه المنطقه يبنى عبر اذا عبر اا ت- همم
دعم الهويات الفرعيه وهذا الكلام واضح بما
معنى بما هو الهاويات الفرعيه الحوثي حزب
الله بشار الاسد الحشد الشعبي ولكن
بالمناسبه الحشد الشعبي ليس هو كل ما يمثل
المجتمع الاغلبي في العراق لان المجتمع
الاغلبي في العراق اي الشيعه انتخابيه
وتشرينيا بكثوره اثبت ان هويتهم الوطنيه
بتعريفاتها المتعدده هم هم ليسوا جزءا من
فائض الخرائط الايرانيه او المجال الحيوي
الايراني كما ان اي دوله في مجالها الحيوي
او ايران في فكره همم سيطره على مجالها
الحيوي ايران دوله تصدر ازماتها الى
الخارج كلام على الخامنئي في هذه اللحظه
لان النظام مهدد في شرعته الداخليه فهو
يصدر ازمته الى الخارج
بالخارج من اجل ضمان استقرار الداخل جزء
من ادواته المسيرات النووي القضيه الكرديه
القضيه البلوشيه والان يفتح المجال الحيوي
لانه ايضا سرق القضيه الفلسطينيه يحاول ان
يحاول اللعب على على مواضيع خاصه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وليس الا قناعه الا ادراك
منه بانه ازمه الداخل المتراكمه يصدرها
الى الخارج يلهي الخارج بهذه المصطلحات
الجيسيه والتفكيرات الامبراطوريه لعله
يحافظ على استقراره في مرحله انتقامه
دقيقه واحده لا احد يضمن مستقبل نظام
الايراني
من خلال هذه التصريحات الهدف منها هو
تصدير الاحتجاجات بالداخل او الازمه
الداخليه للخارج هل ينجح في ذلك تعتقد
لا اعتقد في ظل المعطيات الدوليه نتفق مع
الدكتور مصطفى في ظل المعطيات الدوليه
الحاليه هو اولويه البقاء وبالتالي يحاول
ان يقول هناك فاسيج خارج حدود ايران
يدافعون عن باسيرا عن نظام ايران ولهذا
كشف هذه الاستراتيجيه كشف الاستراتيجيه
بسبب التوتر الداخلي في حين في زمن نجاد
وفي زمن الروحاني كشفوها لانهم كانوا
يريدون ان يتوسعوا كما فعلوا مع العواصم
الاربعه همم استاذ عدنان
باختصار شديد لم تجبني منذ قليل على سؤالي
بخصوص العراق همم التهامتها ايران او
بنسبه معينه همم لانك قلت بان هذا التعامل
عادي همم بين طرفين همم
ما جوابك لم تجبني على سؤال
لا سيدي عزيزه انا ما اقول تعامل عادي
اقول هاي نظريات ثابته في العلوم السياسيه
الاستاذ عبد الفتاح خلينا ننسى او سراج
همم العلوم السياسيه والتعاملاته لانه حتى
هذه التعريفات لديها كذلك محطات تاريخيه
قد تختلف فيها العوامل من مرحله لمرحله
ولكن بالنسبه للعراق في الوقت الحالي ضيف
يقول بان ايران التهامتها ولم تعد تمتلك
هويه بداخلها هل هذا صحيح او مبالغ فيه
سيد سيد طبعا هذا خطر يعني هذا كلام خطير
جدا العراق لا زال هذا العراق انا اقول
اليوم عندما احتل العراق سنه 2003 كانت
الجيوش الامريكيه تصوير وتجول واكثر من 36
دوله بريطانيا والعالم كله يصوله ويجود
فكيف يمكن للعراقي يعني يتماسك مع اقرب
الدول له يعني ليس هي امام في حذف كذلك
داعش وكذلك القاعده ما الذي استطاع ان
يقاومه يعني العراق عندما يفتش سيادتي او
المواطن يفتش عن وجودك عندما جاءت داعش
هددت الوجود الشيعي بالدرجه الاولى
والوجود العراقي بدرجه الثانيه بل ارادت
ان تتسح الى الخليج وتمتد الى ايران تاكيد
رونالدو تفكر عن مجال الدعم العراقي في
هذا
ايران هي التي كذلك
دعمت من القاعده
ولما
هربانه
العراق العراق احنا نتكلم
بما فيها ايران وامريكا والعالم الامارات
وغيرها تقدمت في الكثير من المساعدات
العراقي انا اقول في حاله العراق اذا اراد
فعلا يفتش عن مجال الحيويه واصلا وجوده
تعرضه للخطر من خلال الاحتلال الامريكي من
خلال القاعده من خلال داعش كيف يمكن ان
يفكر بواقع الاجتماعي وواقع السياسي
وضحت الفكره في كل الحالات اكيد يحتاج الى
اخرين نعم على كل سنه نبقى في متابعه هذه
التصريحات وتداعياتها هل ستصدر لازمه
بالخارج سنتابع لنرى وشكركم جزيل الشكر من
اسطنبول السيد عمر عبد الستار من بغداد
دكتور عدنان سراج ومن لبنان دكتور مصطفى
فحص شكرا